let's go back in time about 1800 years
ago to the year
145 a.d a time when everyone ate organic
food because that's all there was
and nobody listened to dubstep over in
greece
some guy had a dream where the god of
medicine told him his son needed to be a
doctor
so he sent his son galen to med school
the medicine god knew what he was
talking about because galen became the
most famous doctor
in ancient history but that's not why
we're here today
we're here to talk about the guy that
took him down william harvey
for a long long time everyone knew that
your body was made up of four fluids
called humors
blood phlegm yellow bile and black bile
people thought of these fluids the same
way some people today think about
genetics
a handy explanation for like everything
so
say you had a bad temper that meant you
had tons of yellow bile inside
but if you were all detached and
unemotional your body was probably full
of phlegm
galen grabbed this idea and ran with it
coming up with lots of medical
treatments mostly involving cutting
people
open and letting their blood drain out
his medical books were so popular
they rocked the best seller list for the
next 1500 years
and that's when william harvey steps in
we've gone past the dark ages
the middle ages and the renaissance but
the medical world is still all about
galen
harvey's a young hot shot doctor to
british royalty who's got it made if he
plays his cards right
there's only one problem he's way too
curious
galen was smart but limited for one
thing
he never got to test his theories
because cutting dead people open was a
big no-no back in the day
it pretty much killed your chances of
getting into heaven so galen had to
figure things out either by guessing
or by dissecting dead animals which was
kinda but not
totally useful when talking about humans
but harvey's got no qualms with slicing
up dead people
even though surgery is considered a
pretty trashy career move and done
only by low-class barbers he's inspired
by a couple of renaissance doctors named
vesalius and fabricius who are
revolutionizing the world of medicine
but they've got way too big a man crush
on galen to really challenge his ideas
in a major way
not so with harvey whose curiosity leads
him to ask more and more questions
every time he digs into those corpses
galen claimed that blood was produced in
the liver and then sent up to different
parts of the body
which used it up harvey says that makes
no sense blood travels in a circle from
the heart
through the arteries into the veins and
then back into the heart
galen thought there were two kinds of
blood harvey's like no
just one but it changes color when it
mixes with oxygen
he finally goes public with his stuff in
1628
with his book deimotu cordus which
roughly translated means
everyone's a [ __ ] except me the book
doesn't just update galen's theories it
completely disproves them
if blood circulates around the body like
harvey claims none of galen's theories
make much sense
including digestion respiration and all
of that cool bloodletting stuff
not surprisingly people go all medieval
in harvey's ass
even though everyone does it from a
different angle doctors who've spent
their entire careers practicing galen's
theories are understandably threatened
by harvey's ideas
so they diss him every chance they get
on the flip side
philosophers like rene descartes who's
trying to prove that the universe is
just a wicked big machine
support harvey's theories but only the
parts that fit their agenda
it's like if someone today discovered
that humans actually evolved from
martian
space rocks you can bet that both
evolutionary scientists
and creationists would have a big
problem with that for totally different
reasons
even if the evidence proved it to be
true for the next couple of decades
it's harvey versus everybody all the
royal doctors who once loved him now
call him a nutcase and harvey basically
ditches everyone to work on other
research
choosing to just ignore the haters by
the 1650s william harvey's a grumpy old
man who's watched his wife die
and has had the british parliament send
thugs to his place to steal most of his
research
making him bust out with the phrase man
is but a great mischievous baboon
but it's not all depressing news he
still teaches his anatomy lessons from
time to time
and a new generation of med students
treat him like a rock star
embracing his work and applying it to
their own research
by the time he dies william harvey has
been lucky enough to see his work
vindicated
a prize most misunderstood geniuses
never get
and galen king of the world for 1 500
years
fades into pop culture obscurity
suffering the same fate as friendster
and jamiroquai
[Music]
[Music]
you